yeah your opinion about tick tock
go man it's fantastic and i'm sorry stop
stop just say you hate it just say
oh my god all these these these short
jokes it's just vine all over again
oh my god and they're collecting all of
our data's and they're going to send it
to the chinese and
there we go that's my boy
okay but if we're going to react to it
oh
oh i love it am i still supposed to
have we fallen that far to where we're
going to start being coming to tick-tock
reaction is that all the attention span
we have
six seconds oh no
you're the chosen one what have they
done well we'll see if we can find one
that can make
can change your mind okay okay yeah okay
let's try this one
okay can you ready i'm ready
[Music]
i was trying to harmonize you're the one
that stopped me all right look at my
reverb reverb there we go
[Music]
what's wrong with you all right hey guys
so i got this new bug zapper today i was
hoping to zap some bugs it's very like
electrical
so like if i had a [ __ ]
that's a funny tick tock we did it
exactly
lola's fine she does that all the time
she likes to eat the electricity it's
funny and then but
if you like the production side you got
like the dog sitting there on the ground
the whole time like wagging it in front
of the dog like don't ruin the tick tock
come on okay
you know this is totally impromptu like
this
who cares about the details i'm just
saying you can recreate it pretty easily
if you wanted to probably
well you're just a ball of fun aren't
you all right well i thought
i'm confused do i hate tick tock or do i
love it which one do i do
we're gonna find out such an us thing
jenna what's in your turtleneck
i actually said this just to send to
marseille because
it made me laugh licking that kermit in
a turtleneck
oh man rip jenna i hate that she
canceled herself
if only tick tock would cancel
themselves instead oh my god
mary was telling me about a tick tock
earlier today uh about a girl that was
saying that she buys like a bunch of
i don't know day planners or something
or journals
oh my god yeah yeah and and then resells
them
right and then everyone comments like oh
how could you do that you're uh you scam
i'm never buying these again it's like
you're just a store that's exactly what
every store in the world does
no she's a young entrepreneur she's drop
shipping you guys don't get it
it's yeah there's so many dumb economies
i mean i don't want to be a super boomer
here i got my boomer shirt on right now
you know but
like do you not guys not know how like
the people on tik tok not know how
just anything works out the people on
tiktok likes to pretend like
no one's ever known anything about
economy or how to make money
before it's so strange
the person i sent you this wants you to
know we need to get the gang together
when you're getting ready come on
this is my favorite one where they make
fun of other people making tech talks
hey yeah i need to get him
[Music]
oh god what is this hair this is average
tick tock user right here
man what is it what is good on this look
at that arrow what is it what is that
just a bunch of you gotta have like
arrow wouldn't that random numbers
tattoo snakes
more jewelry than clothing basically to
be on tick tock you have to be an anime
like protagonist or a villain what the
with it it's this haircut
it's like i kind of like it it looks
like a [ __ ] hedgehog like
i mean i can't make too much fun my hair
is always awful you know how you do the
hair
this looks like you might put my chest
on his head i think
all right let's see what this fella has
to say if i have to go for chapstick and
she just pulls me to kiss me
i would say no i
[Laughter]
i like this they're fighting back
against the cringe i love it
i want some chips you know i just need
to smash my booty
[Laughter]
oh yeah so the everyone talks about the
tech talk algorithm and how like it
changes based on your interests and yada
yada
yeah so i'm getting into the conspiracy
zone this week i just got a ton of
conspiracy [ __ ]
and this is one saying experts have been
unable to explain this statue which has
been found in a church built in the
1600s
the statue appears to show a man in
modern day astronaut suit
including air tubes it's a newly made
sculpture
on an old building that's it that's
it thank you wow and i really appreciate
filming the ceiling but
oh my gosh thank you conspiracy
wow blow my mind this means aliens
it's got to you know this building is
old you know that means everything on
the building even the renovations are
old
my mind is blown if astronaut and
building is real i mean think about how
deep the
rabbit hole goes everything is real now
everything
even the matrix and all of it choose one
mask to wear and you gain
all the ability from the character who
wears it which one would you pick
ken uh just give me batman so i'll just
be rich ooh that's smart
let's see what's one mask to wear and
you gain
all the abilities from the character who
wears it
i am gonna go with the mask okay
nice why did you why did you save this
one
so boring why is it the hair i don't
give a [ __ ]
i mean to be fair the strongest mask on
here is the spawn mask you know
by far but still you know no it's v for
for data mask for oh my god
you can say a bunch of v words in one
long monologue
okay okay i got a good one
[Music]
[Applause]
come on
[Music]
hell yeah so if i had to keep putting
the cat down and just like fine
eventually put the little fur hat on my
head i guess take pictures
here's a here's a brain thought for you
yes
the hat the cat or it's the cat hat why
you shot boat me again
[Laughter]
what can i say i read knee nietzsche you
know this oh yeah
i'm just uh in a different mindset than
everyone else
you know what i wonder what these cats
this is the scottish uh scottish fold
with the ears i wanted one so bad i'm
allergic to cats
i want whatever this cat got going on
you know
[Music]
over there
it sounds beautiful what would you do if
i broke it to your house
[Music]
and shoot him someone made this
can look as lethal as possible
okay and then reveal your own lethalness
all right let me see hang on again i
gotta take my intersectionness
[Music]
what would you do if we broke into your
house huh
what would you do i would pick the beef
or vendetta mask because that's the best
mask
that's a sexy boy i was waiting for him
like squat down and like had the vodka
you know
i was waiting to see that ass come on
i like the string that's wrapped around
the top of it too to hold it on oh
that's how they did it very nice good
pick
all right this is a life hack candy you
can do that
cool right
this guy is [ __ ] great
[Laughter]
the freaking life hacks are just like
make your life more complicated
oh my god they really fixed pizza for us
what were we doing before this there's
another tick tock that mary had showed
me to where it's like um
the life hack that had a flip over or
like a grilled cheese and they like pick
up the whole pan and like flip it onto
the
it was like this whole thing and the
dude was like get grabbed a dispatch and
just flipped it over and it was like you
can also use the spatula yes
there's so many of these it's like yeah
they all ran out of ideas and they're
just
so desperate now you need that content i
feel like some people on tick tock got
it figured out to where you do
dumb things like this so that people
will you know yeah you bait them right
yeah that's a whole genre you know what
that little table is even for
uh so not make the cheese hit the hit
the top i mean ken i'm not
i'm not that oblivious to american
culture all right i know you've been
killing me and now she's
very important all right i haven't feel
every episode's like all right this is
america felix or
this is how babies work i know now
you know i know now you know that i know
now have you have you read the comments
i don't dare to read our comments
because it's always like felix is an
idiot
and it's the greatest and i don't like
how this has changed
i feel like ken's just trying to get
felix ready to have his own baby and i'm
scared for him i'm like yeah
i didn't have any anytime soon oh dude
the freak the last baby video mary gave
me like a 10 minute speech
about like like how does he not know
that babies just drink milk they don't
eat food
i'm just like mary i think he's just
trolling i think
got him oh that makes me happy i'm sorry
mary
or is he trolling that's the real
question is he trolling
who knows i mean just feed them dog food
like i
have you tried it i don't know i don't
get it let's do this
good little manga
oh nice he did it again i'm a winner
oh my god
oh sorry guys sorry guys i didn't mean
to do that
that was a rocket accident all right
there's no more mocking around guys
all right no more rocketing people oh my
god
i can't believe you did it so many
[Music]
i'm reporting you i'm reporting man this
is
this is pretty tame for you know xbox
live comments yeah
it probably took him a long time to get
these clips of people just not yelling
you know some stuff at him and talking
about his mom and things
hey no more mucking about what's a
better christmas movie elf or scrooge
help go scrooge help
so good they just had an epic
interaction
sometimes all you gotta do is point
what's a better christmas movie elf or
scrooge
elf no scrooge help
[Music]
such a great interaction he just stands
there like
[Laughter]
oh what would be your version of that
who's a better youtuber pewdiepie
all right okay
i don't know i don't have a thing i
don't i don't have a oh you don't know a
thing
yeah ah what that shirt
that's that shirt america
babies barbecue sauce
wait what barbecue yeah barbecue sauce
of course
i actually want you to see this way it's
not interesting but
[Music]
come on i've been one of these boys and
i was terrified
[Music]
look at that that's clean that's clean
he's a guy
and then just stares them down like yeah
that's right do you know what they
did to us before we i i don't know what
it's called in english you catch the
ball right
for the pro players so i've done that on
a pro pro match when i was very young
and you know what these [ __ ] told us
right before what
they told us that someone got hit in the
balls by a serve and they died instantly
do you know how scared i was being there
i was so terrified oh my god
that's he's scared right now he's
fearing for his life
such a thing [ __ ] god i caught that
oh he's just frozen in fear he does
you know what i was thinking about that
actually i'm like it's pretty fair to
die
if that happens your balls get crushed
i'm happy to die instantly
that's the funniest tick tock i've seen
in a long time well done
the ugh what would you do
[Laughter]
i know well yeah you would you wouldn't
do it ken i know you wouldn't do it to
me
yeah i mean all right like
you're like my bff of course you know i
would not
take that money and run do you know
i would i would use i would i'll make
sure that you get that money and it's
used to treat
your injury oh right be like hey felix
can i get a percentage
by the way i saved your life where's my
money
okay here's another crazy conspiracy and
i
yeah it's gonna find destroyed
structures everywhere you can find
remnants of ancient civilizations and
cities venus as well we've discovered
what appear to be structures
massive structures all of these by the
way have pyramids treatments on our own
perimeter
venus all the way across the whole solar
system there were two pyramid wars these
war
pyramid wars [ __ ] i don't teach you
about that
history but i miss that on the pyramid
board
are we allowed to share this pyramid
there
she lasers at the top of the pyramid
pyramids on venus were like ah
a bunch of aliens just looking around
for like real estate like i'm putting a
pyramid in there no i'm putting a
pyramid in there
pyramid wars oh god control of humans
control of land especially on venus
gotta control that land on venus
the genetic codes went on by [ __ ] star
maps in them and it's claims whoever has
them has control over the earth
i don't know the context maybe he's just
making up some [ __ ] i have no idea but
it sounds great was that like a block of
ramen they just showed you're talking
about dna
[Laughter]
looking tasty what is this
is that whole wheat i love genetic codes
this is also from forbidden knowledge
you're not supposed to know this you're
not supposed to know the pyramid wars
i don't remember why i say this i'm
looking forward to this 26
of people have a narrator inside their
head so you know that little voice in
your head
i don't believe that everyone has a
voice in their head
what does your voice sound like you
better buy better skippers
[Laughter]
wow all right
it's almost ready cooked the egg is
getting there bro that's what it's
saying all the time
what is it i know i know though that
some people don't have it
at all that's something yeah right like
yeah
whenever i think of things i think of it
like as like a movie
like i play it out and then i even play
like different outcomes out
like like like this like it's a movie
an egg yeah yeah yeah kind of like that
and i'm like but what if you know
that old commercial like this is your
brain on crack and the lady like cracks
the egg on the stove what if she like
hits that dude why's his eyeball like
being drawn in right there it's like
this weird little eyeball thing
can you get me out of here get me out of
your head i want to be here this is a
weird place
all the time
are you like always looking at the worst
scenario or what does that
i don't get what you're getting at i
just think about a lot of
stuff and then i stutter a lot because i
can't pick like one idea i want to latch
on to and go with
that's interesting i don't i can't
relate to this i'm uh
curious if other people aren't i don't
know what's yours you just see what you
see and then you you think what you
think
i don't know an egg eggplant pan egg
simple i don't i don't know maybe i'm
not the 26
[ __ ] oh shoot i just i'm jealous this
guy has surround sound in his head right
there did you see that i got the
speakers on the wall
oh you smell asparagus pee i do
[ __ ] i do smell sparing a species
i don't do you no i don't i don't
why it's like as soon as i eat the
asparagus like 30 minutes later i go to
the bathroom i'm like woof man
experience my pee myself feeds me as
fragrance and then she complaining and
i'm like i don't know
everyone can smell it no oh sneezing is
on light i heard about it but that
happens to me
sometimes it's not just because you go
outside you have allergies i think i
watched a very tiresome video they
thought it was because in caves
you know cave people ugabuga it was
better to not spread germs while you're
in the cave so people
automatically seems when they left the
game and that's just still in our dna
what yeah it's in our dna to sneeze when
we go outside of a cave
well like it's specific right there bro
i i got the oogabooga dna because i do
it sometimes yeah
yeah you just walk outside and the
sunlight makes you sneeze not like
nature or anything not like all these
flowers it was a very passive video
it's confirmed all right
just a youtuber what do i know yeah
thank you
the most bizarre phenomenon in the world
have you heard about the world
and the whole world yeah world
encyclopedia
two encyclopedias are so good they made
a second one phenomenon in the world
there is a mysterious giant causeway in
northern ireland
it is an eight kilometer coast made up
of forty thousand hexagonal stone
pillars
tourists take such a mysterious video at
that time tourists photographed a stone
indeed suddenly opening it up and then
it is
no reason this strange phenomenon seems
spreading local experts came to surveys
like us to peas and shimmer
there was no sign of fraud in the video
no sign of fraud
[Music]
that is real i love the smoke that flies
on the bottom of it too
it plays a little further ken there's no
sign of fraud i mean this is written
it's right arguing like play the video
look at that look at the
dust that flies up
it doesn't come off the side of it or
anything there's only dust on the ground
there's there's just no sign uh that's
how
they operate the northern ireland
there's doors like my god the rocks are
moving
that's where the leprechauns are hiding
ken i got the gold
that's where all the gold is we gotta
get jacked yeah we gotta find jack
jack tell us about the no sign of fraud
we know there's no sign of fraud where
is it
where's the goal where's the gold
the video surface
although a seemingly dangerous stunt we
are told they took all the
necessarily dangerous get out of here
quite like this
freaking roasted by the end of what's
believed to be
aloha it's sweden it feels like this
should be russia or some [ __ ]
i figured this would be like where i
live you know
i guess we'll do the same thing we'll
just use like atvs and four-wheelers and
cars and just
drag each other around and this one does
that's what happens when you don't have
water in a hundred years
to a country yeah we gotta
do something with this you know these
tax dollars to work man
have you ever tried making a chicken and
veggie one pen meal
no i never have but have you guys ever
made your own kaleidoscope before
this is like a virtual world this is
like a regional world
no i haven't but while i got your
attention here
have you guys ever tried to do something
really basic and boring no but look at
this
oh this one is fantastic in your soda
cans the traditional way
oh let me share a heck i recently found
the secret is in the can handle hanger
let me show you with a new can
all you need is some shoelace slide the
string through the can handle and just
pull
gonna try it open so easy
this is clearly a bait but it's really
funny this is where the bait ones i like
how she's got the cans hanging up by the
in the refrigerator too we don't do that
in america
no no no no just so disappointed the
motherfucker's got like a whole drawer
that keeps all my cans nice and chilled
at the perfect temperature
that's the thing i miss about sweden we
can leave our cans in the window
and then they're nice and cold oh my god
i don't know if i
mean i miss the cans being cold but i
mean just to be in that cold in general
no wonder you left
yeah but the only perk called cans baby
cold
tall tanks every time baby i didn't want
my my parents to know about all the red
bulls i drank as well so i would keep
them out there nice and chill
and right outside your windows reach out
and grab one it gives you wings
do you think star wars is nardiken uh i
think it's just a movie but people are
nerdy about it
all right well this is gonna change your
mind
has your opinion changed yet ken no
it's cool though it's cool but like what
is this caption
show this to anyone that says star wars
is nerdy uh
they were watching like yeah it's still
nerdy they're like this is freaking
robot dude with a
laser sword you know that's pretty
it's fairly nerdy oh this is great
oh parkour whoa whoa
oh god no no
no no i thought the fence was going to
fall over what is this castle this
dracula's castle in the background holy
crap
this is a regular europe city okay
what it's crazy this is a church
get out of here man that's wild me oh so
i can tell you about europe now
well you see you can't tell about the
cool gothic buildings yeah i don't
know i love watch mojo
no i'm always look i'm almost watching
the top 10 things always
going to watch mojo yeah that's me oh no
no you never do that oh my god can you
do the intro for us
right now please i've never done this in
person
welcome to watch mojo she's real
she's real i thought it was a robot what
the heck is this
wow this is unbelievable
i've never actually seen anybody get
excited about watching like this
it's so great it's watch mom job
say the thing
you guys are wondering what these things
are up here so they're gonna be like
five pounds so you pull the lever
and pull it down awesome tips there i
wanted to add on to that actually
if you look right here on the dumbbells
the numbers on here
actually mean you know that's how heavy
it is
god bless him so good damn
you're about to get as well as him now
that you have um unlock this for better
knowledge my god i need to start the gym
again i just keep getting fatter
uh love it all right kim i hope uh
actually i don't care what your opinion
has changed
that's all the tech talk i got to show
you me oh thank
thank god it's over i oh i like tik tok
because it's a
sometimes you find really funny ones
like the the lottery ticket one and then
a lot of it is really cringy so it's
still fun to me like i get it yeah
i get a kick out of it regardless i
think anyway
people can express their creativity no
matter how cringe it is it's fantastic
no and then yeah then we get to react to
it yeah it's fine and hopefully you
don't get claimed on anything so haha
we all win there we go tech talk solved
thank you ken
all right one last time as an outro
i dig again again subscribe to me
see you tomorrow